bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat ce matin je vous propose de suivre
la table ronde organisée la semaine
dernière par la mission d'information
commune sur la politique en faveur des
jeunes
cette mission présidée par la sénatrice
raymonde le texier a souhaité donner la
parole aux radios et aux chaînes de
télévision les plus écoutées par les 16
25 ans objectif comprendre les attentes
et les besoins des jeunes mais également
savoir comment les pouvoirs publics
pouvaient s'adresser plus efficacement à
cette tranche d'âge bonne matinée à tous
sur public sénat vient nous allons
continuer par cette table-ronde radio
télévision à destination d'un public
jeune
donc nous accueillons l'eau rendue mais
voilà qui est directeur général d' ado
fm
jérôme fouqueray directeur général de
fun radio et il ya un gène est directeur
des chaînes musicales du groupe m6 merci
madame la brillante dégoûté d'abord
merci de devenir un autre de répondre
présent à notre invitation je vois
excusé tout de suite pierre bellanger
khwaja interrupteur général de skyrock
qui devrait être là mais qui s'est
décommandé il ya quelques il ya quelques
minutes
alors pourquoi les radios libres j'ai
fait un propos liminaire fort pour toi
par dans les rues de pourquoi les radios
et les tv
aujourd'hui parce que nous essayons dans
cette mission de recevoir tous celles et
ceux qui s'intéressent ou prendre de
jeunesse pour les jeunes nous avons des
jeunes structuré qui sont les étudiants
et nous reprenons nous avons donc ici
les représentants des étudiants opposés
avant auditionné pour les autres c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué quand j'ai dit
les autres c'est les jeunes qui sont
sortis du système éducatif à 16 ans qui
sont bacheliers mais qui n'ont pas su
fait d'études supérieures on a du mal à
vraiment appréhender leurs problèmes
même si nous sommes tous élus nous ils
recevront beaucoup de jeunes dans l'eau
permanence on n'a pas le même auditoire
que vous donc l'idée de vous inviter
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous puissiez
nous dire à travers les émissions à
travers les forums halte rappelle débat
que vous avez quel état grosso modo de
la jeunesse et comment on peut les aider
à partir des problématiques qu'ils
pourraient vous exprimer donc j'ai trois
questions simples comment aujourd'hui
les jeunes utilisent les médias comme
espace d'expression qui a qu'est-ce
qu'il vous dise
d'une manière générale quel est l'état
d'esprit des jeunes aujourd'hui d'après
le miroir des médias et enfin à
l'utilisation d'internet une idée phone
mobile at elle modifié la relation des
jeunes aux médias alors d'abord je me
présente je m'appelle jérôme fouqueray
je m'occupe depuis quelques années de
fun radio dont c'est une radio dont le
programme est constitué de deux choses
importantes de musique évidemment
puisque c'est le indécent enfin c'est
l'objet de la consommation principal de
des jeunes des 16-25 en matière de radio
et de ce qu'on appelle des missions
parlé avec une dimension qui est plus de
divertissement le matin dans l'union qui
a trait à l'humour et au dialogue le
soir ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs la
libre antenne d'ailleurs j'ajoute que
je
et qu'elles doivent d'ailleurs être
financé par les jobs qu'on appelle des
mcjobs j'ai vu ça dans la presse cette
difficulté particulièrement forte sur
les populations issues de la diversité
les populations urbaines d'origine
africaine ou maghrébine
on ressent très fortement je sais pas
s'il ya un échec global ou pas des
politiques de la ville c'est évidemment
pas à moi de le dire mais en tout cas
nous on ressent fortement
une vraie fracture sur ce type de
population il ya d'autres éléments qui
sont qui sont importants qui sont plus
positifs moi je sens aussi que c'est un
travail que l'on fait nous au niveau
marketing sur la radio par rapport au
marketing on développe jeu sans prise de
conscience très très forte des jeunes
sur plein de sujets très importants et
plein de sujets qui sont qui hérite
d'être défendu une envie de participer
je viens de libre antenne ont un très
grand succès il ya une montée à une
volonté de participer de s'impliquer sur
les débats actuels qui est très très
forte de s'investir même je dirais dans
des causes qui sont que les jeunes
estiment comme juste il ya aussi une
méfiance vis-à-vis de l'hyper marketing
et centrait fort aussi une espèce de
prise de conscience de mise à distance
des univers qui sont 10 milliards
purement marchand
et on se méfie de ça et on essaye de
développer un marketing pur marketing
justement sincère positifs et qu'ils
soient pas uniquement de l'hyper martin
de vente
voilà quelque chose qui est totalement
nouveau qui est le fait que tous ces
gamins communique de façon immédiate
entre grâce aux nouveaux outils de
communication gratuite
je pense évidemment facebook je pense à
myspace qui sont des outils fantastiques
de communication des gamins entre eux
est d'ailleurs d'aider des radios et de
nos médias avec ces jeunes
moi j'ai fait la somme de tous les
groupes par exemple sur facebook qui
sont concernés par notre média sur fun
radio
ça concerne 80 mille jeunes qui ont
entre 13 et 22 ans
donc auquel on s'adresse de façon auquel
on peut s'adresser de façon directe
immédiate et quotidienne sur tous les
sujets qui nous concernent soit pour
vendre des choses avant des choses je
parle pas de vente marchands mais de
vendre nos émissions vendent nos avants
notre marketing mais surtout avec lequel
on peut dialoguer et d'ailleurs la
plupart des remontées je vous fais la
queue dont j'ai fait une petite synthèse
viennent de
viennent beaucoup de ces dialogues à la
fois des jeunes avec nous avec nous
mêmes mais aussi des jeunes entre eux
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire de
façon de façon un peu synthétique
il ya un dernier élément c'est que on a
vu des hommes politiques sur un fun
radio
on leur donne la parole alors moi le
choix que je fais c'est pas forcément
d'inviter des hommes politiques parce
que sont les hommes politiques mais des
hommes politiques qui ont des parcours
exemplaire et qui sont intéressants à
partager c'est à dire dès ce soir des
parcours de réussite ou des gens qui ont
fait des choses qui méritent d'être
partagées avec les gamins selon moi je
remarque quand même que les les jeunes
qui nous écoutent ont très envie de
dialoguer ils ont très envie de discuter
ils ont très envie de faire partager
leurs angoisses et leurs avis sur sur la
politique et les parcours ça qu'on a
invité rachat d'ati il ya quinze jours
sur fun qui a été un énorme succès au
standard il ya vingt-six mille appels en
une soirée jeux pas si vous imaginez on
a eu 80 personnes qui ont pu passer sur
l'antenne y en a eu besoin de six mille
appels au standard nadine morano était
venu nous expliquer à deux mois les
projets en matière de politique
familiale et jack lang était venu nous
faire une sorte de debrief un peu sur
l'éducation les l'avenir en matière de
politique éducative
voilà donc il ya un besoin
il ya une envie et il ya moi je sens pas
du jeu sans pas de rejet je sens une
défiance par rapport à un parent un
discours serait trop construit serait
trop marketing mais j'en suis une vraie
sincérité et une vraie envie de partager
de discuter
dans un dialogue qui est décomplexé
simple franc et fraternelle comme l'ont
pu être les trois dialogue qu'on a eue
sur l'antenne qui était vraiment super
en termes de vérité de sincérité de
proximité avec les jeunes il y aura des
questions tout à l'heure donc vous
pourrez pas compris
on continue dans l'ordre de vous êtes
installé par exemple s'il de passer
après un si brillante exploser donc je
suis un jeune est je m'occupe de la
musique pour la chaîne m6 je m'occupe je
dirige également les chaînes m6music sur
le câble et le satellite et l'adsl et je
coordonne la musique pour l'ensemble du
groupe m6 pour prolonger ce que dit
jérôme parce qu'on est on exactement sur
la même perception est sur le même
constat
nous on identifie et donc pour aller un
peu plus dans le réel on identifie trois
mots clés qui que nous expriment les
jeunes en tout cas la perception qu'on
en a d'une part les jeunes demande du
respect il demande à ce qu'on les
respecte et notamment si on doit ces de
matérialiser c'est un petit peu ils ne
veulent pas de jeunisme
donc si on doit réfléchir tout de suite
aux actions de communication
ils refusent parce qu'ils voient à ce
moment là qu'on est dans le faux et que
on essaie juste de s'adapter à eux et
qu'on ne sait pas de les traiter d'égal
à égal
tous les codes du jeunisme
qu'ils perçoivent comme du marketing
cure et donc qu'ils rejettent
immédiatement
c'est le premier point respect c'est je
pense la première étape c'est
fondamental d'autre part et ça peut être
un peu surprenant les jeunes sont en
demande de repères parce qu'aujourd'hui
le constat est assez violent alors c'est
valable notamment pour une frange qui
est potentiellement dans la
marginalisation mai
aujourd'hui il y en a un certain nombre
qui nous disent ne rien avoir à quoi se
raccrocher
ils ont besoin de repères et on a même
un constat qui est assez récent en tout
cas qui s'est renforcée récemment qui
est une réelle demande d'autorité ce qui
est quand même assez de nouveau c'est
que ils ne veulent pas forcément quand
les brosse dans le sens du poil
ils peuvent même aller jusqu'à demander
le coup de pied aux fesses quoi en tout
cas avoir un cadre dans lequel évolué et
que les choses soient dites parfois de
manière un peu abrupte mais au moins
qu'elle soit dit franchement clairement
et directement ils sont pas forcément
dans un avec un sentiment de révolte
en tout cas s'il y a 2 doit y avoir un
sentiment ou une volonté transgression
elle reste assez sage ne rien ils sont
pas jusqu'à la révolte physique et c'est
en tout cas pas en masse mais mais en
tout cas ils sont demande de repères et
ce qu'ils nous disent
en tout cas je cite une des remarques
qui nous faisait dans des groupes
qualitatif auquel on leur a demandé de
participer c'est qu'ils souhaitent de la
part des adultes une forme d'autorité
ils veulent que soient marquées
l'autorité il veut que l'adulte joue son
rôle finalement parce que
potentiellement dans la cellule
familiale
ils n'ont plus cette autorité ou tout
quoi plus suffisamment qui fait que les
parcours personnel sont parfois petit
peu biaisé et puis autre chose qui est
assez surprenant une troisième point
c'est qu'il
ils sont
dès l'adolescence donc les par exemple
et 16 ans puisque c'est le début de la
cible qui est concerné par cette
discussion regarde l'avenir de manière
extrêmement concrètes
ils sont déjà dans le concret je vais
faire un parallèle je veux parler de
manière plus précise
par rapport à l'antenne de m6 donc on
n'est pas sur la musique on n'est pas
sur des projets générationnel mais il ya
eu une des émissions qui marchent très
bien sûr les sur les moins de 25 ans qui
et recherche appartement et un gamin de
22 16 ans aujourd'hui il n'est pas du
tout dans cette logique et juste en
train d'essayer de préparer son bac et
quand on les interroge sur le succès que
remporte cette émission sur cette cible
à ils nous disent que ça leur permet
déjà de se projeter et de voir à quel
problème il va être confronté quelques
années après et 10 pensent dès cet âge
là ils sont déjà dans le concret y
réfléchisse évidemment problématique des
études thématiques du financement de
leur avenir personnel et c'est de
l'emploi mais de manière extrêmement
concrètes quoi ils y pensent mais
extrêmement matériel ils ont la
perception si on prend un peu de hauteur
ils ont la perception d'un d'une société
extrêmement violente
ça c'est un constat qui est assez
général avec une réelle peur de l'avenir
voilà c'est un constat qu'on peut tout
faire c'est que ils ont une telle
absence de visibilité sur ce que sera
leur avenir à horizon six mois un an
deux ans et a fortiori cinq ans que
alors alors ça concerne c'est une menace
qui consacrait physique qui peut aller
jusqu au physique la violence
quotidienne de la rue menace en terme
d'emploi de l'absence de visibilité
l'éclatement de la cellule familiale et
c'est donc demande de repères donc tout
ça ce corrobore évidemment si on doit
revenir sur la transgression
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'il ya un
certain nombre de médias qui relayent
set des valeurs un peu transgressives
mais de manière assez bordés ça reste
toujours dans dans dance dans certaines
limites
donc il ya une limite mais c'est celle
de la peur la transgression ne va pas la
transaction doit rester ludique donc ça
peut être aussi un axe pour la
communication et la manière de
s'adresser à eux
transgression oui mais enfin elle reste
finalement assez sage certaine limite
pour revenir sur l'aspect sur la
matérialisation et le fait que les
jeunes sont aujourd'hui dans le concret
on peut citer le récent très grand
succès de l'émission zone interdite
dimanche soir sur m6 qui ne vise pas
forcément un public très jeune qui est
même d'ailleurs une des rares émissions
de m6 qui déborde très largement du
public des moins de 50 ans et qui
s'adresse qu'aux mondiaux 4 ans et +
donc aussi bien au moins de 50 ans que
plus de 50 ans donc à une cible plus
âgés que la moyenne des émissions de la
chaîne du groupe m6 et on a recueilli
plus de 30 % d'audience sur les moins de
25 ans ce qui est assez inédit pour
cette émission là avec une thématique
qui va dans le sens de ce que je vous
disais auparavant thématique c'était les
dangers qui guettent les dangers par
donkey dette les ados donc sa traitait
aussi bien des problèmes de drogue
d'alcool d'emploi etc
ils se sont sentis directement concernée
est une problématique assez grave
extrêmement sérieuse qui étaient traités
de manière extrêmement claire concrète
avec des exemples concrets sur le
terrain etc
c'est très exactement ce qu'ils
demandent et les réponses qu'ils
attendent
voilà donc on a pu constater qu' on
était dans le vrai quand on diffusait ce
genre d'émission est en tout cas on
répondait à une de leurs attentes ce qui
est d'en savoir plus et d'avoir
éventuellement des clés pour s'en sortir
un autre point qui doit nourrir la
réflexion par rapport à la manière de
communiquer à la forme
jérôme l'a dit et c'est presque une
lapalissade aujourd'hui mais c'est une
cible qui est extrêmement sensible aux
innovations innovations techniques
notamment
enfin tout ce qui touche aux nouveaux
médias notamment est ce qui leur permet
d'avoir une relation one to one
commandite personnalisé d'être en
relation directe soit avec le média ou
avec le la voie qu'il est qu'il est
qu'ils écoutent au quotidien ou leurs
groupes d'amis ou leurs amis ou leur
famille ou leur alors proche plus ou
moins proche d'ailleurs ils en sont
extrêmement friands donc on doit aussi
être enfin intégrer cette dimension là
dans un an dans la forme de la
communication qui peut d'ailleurs
commencé par une communication
dématérialisés notamment par les
supports web et mobile avant d'investir
les mass media voilà on voit bien qu'ils
aient une réaction immédiate sur ces
médias là avec une efficacité totale
parce qu'il ya évidemment une relation
personnalisée qui permet d'avoir un
message ciblé avant d'élargir évidemment
d'avoir une part de voix beaucoup plus
large et beaucoup plus massives depuis
enfin voilà tout simplement ils ont une
envie
assez incroyable de comprendre le monde
dans lequel il évolue aujourd'hui et le
monde qui les attend ils ont besoin de
clé et je pense que nous en tant que
média on a ce rôle à jouer de leur
donner des clés
il lui aurait expliqué un petit peu où
ils vont comment est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir aller dans la bonne direction
etc
voilà voilà les éléments et le constat
qu'on fait aujourd'hui
merci l'europe et je m'appelle le rendu
mais je suis directeur général associé
d'un groupe s'appelle start qui est dit
petite dizaine de radios locales
indépendantes dont ado voltage et latina
sur paris mais également sud radio dans
le sud
et des radios dans le centre de la
france appelle vibrations forum black
box et wit fm fais ce métier depuis plus
de 25 ans maintenant et nous sommes des
anciens jeunes bacheliers qui n'avons
pas eu le temps de faire des études
supérieures
parce qu'on a été très vite happé par ce
très beau métier qu'est la radio et on a
en aviez au même rythme que les gens qui
nous écoutent est aux débuts de la radio
locale
donc on a une 1re senti de de ce qui
s'est passé depuis plus de 25 ans et de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui mais
contrairement à mes deux confrères je
serai peut-être un petit peu plus bondir
humble sur la ma capacité ou notre
capacité à pouvoir définir ce que sont
les jeunes et ce que veulent les jeunes
aujourd'hui si je le savais de manière
très précise
je serais très très très très content
parce que j'aurai les moyens de pouvoir
rentrer en conversation avec eux et au
fond le but de notre travail c'est
d'arriver à rentrer en conversation avec
eux et c'est même pour nous pas facile
c'est pas facile parce que plus on veut
attaquer des groupes de deux
deux personnes de plus en plus jeunes et
le marketing
je vous rejoins là dessus nous pousse à
aller de plus en plus vers vers des
marchés de gens plus en plus jeune plus
on se retrouve confronté à des à des
grappes
il ya des univers très niche et qui
n'ont pas grand chose à voir les uns
avec les autres et c'est pour ça je vous
le disais moi je parlerai des jeunes
avec humilité parce que je pense que
c'est délicat de parler des jeunes dans
leur ensemble et c'est donc d'autant
plus compliqué de communiquer en
direction des jeunes dans leur ensemble
alors il ya effectivement un certain
nombre d'outils un certain nombre de
médias et des médias qui sont de plus en
plus ciblés et les médias généralistes
nous on est plutôt des médias locaux
si je prends l'exemple de deux radios
comme comme ado qui est qui est une
radio très urbaine entre le début du
succès d'ado et aujourd'hui tout a
changé donc
c'est très compliqué de rester en phase
avec avec avec avec notre public donc
j'aurai beaucoup de difficultés à vous
donner des des pistes très précises pour
pour pour communiquer de manière
certaine avec avec les jeunes
maintenant je pense que la difficulté
enfin l'écueil dans lequel il faut pas
tomber
c'est effectivement le jeunisme sa chute
à fond d'accord avec vous enfin je pense
que tout le monde autour de la table a
des exemples en tête de de soi-même
consommateurs de médias qui visionnent
ou qu'ils écoutent un message des
politiques au sens large en direction de
la jeunesse
c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué de passer un message plaçons
pas pas uniquement en direction des
jeunes
la prévention routière a beaucoup de mal
enfin pourtant il ya un fond derrière
tout ça donc je pense qu'il faut il faut
faire attention de ne pas tomber dans
les travers du jeunisme ça c'est évident
il faut savoir à qui on veut parler
parce que plus on veut parler des gens
jeunes + c
compliqué de s'adresser à eux dans leur
ensemble donc il faut aller par par
petites touches par saupoudrage dans les
directions bien précises effectivement
il ya une partie de la jeunesse qui a
qui a accès à certains noms de deux
nouveaux médias qui communique avec qui
on peut communiquer mais je crains que
ce ne soit qu'une partie de cette
jeunesse parce que pour être même
aujourd'hui pour être connecté il faut
avoir un certain nombre de moyens et
c'est pas parce que on vend beaucoup de
téléphone et que l'adsl s'est
démocratisée que ça touche aujourd'hui
malgré tout l'intégralité des jeunes et
je pense que les jeunes qu'on voudrait
toucher réellement pour ce qui est de la
problématique de la société c'est cela
qui sont plus difficiles à toucher
merci si vous avez d'accord monsieur le
rapporteur je propose qu'on passe au
thème de et préparez vos questions on
posera les questions après le second
exposé donc comment les pouvoirs publics
pour et il s'adresser plus efficacement
aux jeunes pour leur faire connaître les
politiques publiques les concernant si
vous avez des avis là dessus monsieur un
rapporteur va compléter mon propos et
vous prendrez cinq minutes chacun la clé
alors vous avez déjà pour certains
répondu un peu aux questions j'ai opposé
quels impacts de la publicité d'umea
général sur les jeunes et l outil
efficace de prévention et d'information
et comment
j'imagine que vous êtes déjà réfléchi
sur le sujet comment informer les jeunes
et créer des émissions citoyenne alors
que les émissions qui sont proposés
aujourd'hui sont plutôt des émissions
musicales de ou de divertissement et la
troisième question elle les médias
nelson avec s'intitule pas le sentiment
de défiance des jeunes à l'égard de la
société du monde politique en raison de
l'image parfois déformés ou caricatural
qui j'en donne pardon question
subsidiaire
parce que si tu y es sur la publicité je
sais pas comment vous répond enfin oui
oui dans la piste est un très bon moyen
pour faire la promotion des différentes
actions dire on le fait déjà en finale
ya beaucoup de causes et d'action et des
organismes auxquels je pense comme le
thème penser que c'est le cidem 1 pour
voter pour inciter les jeunes à voter il
ya beaucoup de choses qu'on fait en la
matière ce soit des actions sur
l'antenne sur le terrain des actions
entre guillemets citoyenne pour inciter
les jeunes est plus conscient et veiller
à ce type de problématique la police est
un excellent moyen pour le faire
la deuxième chose c'est les émissions
alors comment dire moi je pense que bon
chaque radio à son positionnement
chaque radio est libre de faire le
programme qu'elle souhaite
elle en a fixé d'ailleurs le cadre
par convention avec le csa chaque radio
respecte sa convention au temps de le
faire en tout cas sur sur des sujets
aussi importants que
justement la protection l'adolescence de
l'enfance la promotion des actions de
citoyenneté temps donc il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui sont déjà fait pour
notre parti nous avons des émissions de
divertissement dans lequel nous
intégrons
la dimension dont vous parlez est ce
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
s'inscrit dans ce cadre c'est à dire que
quand on invite des gens qui ont des
choses intéressante à dire ou sur lequel
il ya un dialogue qui est intéressant à
construire avec les jeunes en général on
le fait on le fait pas de façon
systématique mais on le fait à chaque
fois que c'est vraiment intéressant
on l'a fait avec rachida dati on a fait
jack lang et nadine morano cheveux plaie
pour les trois derniers ont fait en fait
toute l'année et à chaque fois qu'on
fait ça marche ça marche très bien il
faut faire attention
les émissions en prime et citoyenne il
faut faire attention qu'elle fasse pas
simplement plaisir aux gens qui les
commandes ont surtout manger on se
retrouve souvent dans des dans des
émissions qui malheureusement sont pas
les plus écoutés ils sont pas les plus
sexy entre guillemets par contre 2 m
d'avoir un programme de divertissement
qui sont un vrai programme responsable
je peux vous assurer là dessus que fun
radio et est vraiment léger sur cette
voie je le dis pas pour agen j'ai
absolument rien à vendre et donc ça fait
partie du positionnement de notre agneau
d'avoir une antenne qui soit une antenne
de bonne humeur de loisirs
mais aussi une antenne qui tirent les
débats vers le haut quand il ya matière
à voir démarre
et encore une fois chacun mes confrères
les positionnements sont pas tous les
mêmes chez des antennes qui sont dommage
parce que je n'ai pas là dont j'aurais
aimé qu'il soit là point alors la
contradiction avec skyrock évidemment
c'est une antenne beaucoup plus installé
dans dans un univers qui n'est pas tout
à fait celui là moi sur fun j'ai fait le
choix encore une fois d'émissions de
divertissement dans lequel on a à chaque
fois que c'est important est que il ya
matière à ont fait on installe un vrai
dialogue et ça se passe vraiment
vraiment très bien donc je me sens pas
comment dire le sentiment de défiance
encore une fois
je le ressens moyennement je ressens
surtout un besoin un besoin
d'explication a besoin de dialogue un
besoin de proximité sans jeunisme et
sans émissions qu'ils soient encore une
fois des émissions qui ne font plaisir
ça me fait toujours penser aux saveurs
aux abonnements des des magazines des
parents qui achètent les magazines pour
les ponts les enfants fait non c'est
prévu que les enfants ne lisent pas ou
en tout cas ça fait plaisir parce que
les enfants les parents ont ses
magazines à la maison bon c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu des émissions dans le passé
ou à la télévision qui sont faites qui
font plaisir aux gens qui les commande
mais malheureusement c'est pas toujours
les plus puissantes
donc il faut arriver à les conseiller et
deux mois je pense que dans des
émissions qui sont des émissions
positive avec des positionnements
divertissement affirmé
on peut faire on peut avoir des tranches
ou des moments qui sont réservées à des
vrais moments de dialogue comme on le
fait quoi ian schultz la parole
répondait en deux points d'une part un
constat c'est que en tout cas pour ce
qui nous concerne un projet qui serait
dont la promesse serait un brin
programme dans la promesse serait un
projet citoyen la citoyenneté comme dit
jérôme se serait pas tellement sexy je
suis pas sûr qu'on arriverait à faire
venir les gens et à chaque fois qu'on a
traité de près ou de loin à la
citoyenneté prendre cette thématique
même si la problématique est là beaucoup
plus large mais c'est parce que c'était
intégré dans une problématique beaucoup
plus large
je prenais résidents de zones interdites
c'est vrai aussi dans 100% mag etc on
voit que sa une sur représentation des
moins de trente et moins de 25 ans sur
ce type d'émission qui est une émission
d'actualité sociétal qui évoque des
sujets plus ou moins légers l'actualité
de manière plus
légère mais aussi des sujets un petit
peu sérieux et traitées de manière très
sérieuse dans lesquels on pourrait
héberger où on peut d'ailleurs le cas
échéant régulièrement héberger des
problématiques liées à la citoyenneté
aux problèmes et aux conditions de vie
des jeunes et sert à leurs attentes
mais je pense pas qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui décemment penser naïvement
que mettre une émission sur une des
antennes radio télé même internet sur un
des supports de médias qu'offre ce pays
une émission dédiée à la citoyenneté
rassemblerait les jeunes de manière
importante voilà je pense que c'est la
forme qui très important que là-dessus
encore une fois je vais prendre un
exemple de ce qui est pour moi un cas
d'école de la manière dont on devrait
travailler pour s'adresser aux moins de
25 ans et donc d'avoir un esprit citoyen
avec une action citoyenne mais qu'il
n'est pas vendu comme ça cette cible là
et qui n'est pas consommée comme ça par
cette cible là c'est un projet qu'on n'a
pas encore signé donc je vous donne une
espèce d'exclusivité là dessus c'est un
projet qui arrive en france en 2009 qui
s'appelle rockcorps
c'est un projet qui est initié par des
américains ils ont monté quatre éditions
de records aux états unis il prépare la
deuxième en angleterre et le principe
est
simplicité biblique mais ces redoutables
c'est qu'il vient un concert qui est
organisée au bout de l'opération
donc là en l'occurrence le concert aura
lieu en france à paris début octobre
2009 et c'est la carotte de l'opération
et pour accéder à ce concert vous n'avez
pas de billetterie
vous n'avez pas de d'invitation n'y a
pas de copinage rien de tout ça il n'y a
pas de passe droit vous êtes obligé de
donner quatre heures de votre temps à
une association
et ça c'est malin parce que évidemment
tout ça se fait de manière extrêmement
festive vous inscrivez ensuite vous êtes
contacté personnellement et suivant
votre localisation géographique on
propose de choisir entre trois
associations humanitaires citoyenne
environnementale etc et ensuite vous
allez sur le terrain mais quand vous
arrivez sur le terrain c'est musique à
fond tout le monde est habillé aux
couleurs de l'opération
et puis il ya un côté communautaire
collectif qui est extrêmement festif et
donc les gens ont l'impression de
participer à une gigantesque fiesta donc
ça se fait de manière extrêmement
positives et au bout des quatre heures
les gars partent avec leur billet en
main et donc d'un coup ils se rendent
compte de la valeur que ça représente
et quand ils arrivent au concert ils
sont fiers parce qu'ils ont donné de
leur temps comme les artistes qui sont
sur scène qui est aussi sont allés sur
le terrain c'est la condition sine qua
none à ce qui monte sur scène est donc
temps les artistes s'adresse à eux ils
ont l'impression de faire partie de la
même famille quoi est ce qui est aussi
génial c'est en tout cas c'est les
exemples qu'on a à l'étranger c'est que
l'opération n'est pas un one shot
puisque près de 40% des jeunes qui
participent aux actions sur le terrain
ensuite s'inscrive durablement dans le
cadre de l'association qu'ils ont aidés
donc on est vraiment sur une action
concrète extrêmement positive avec une
une action moyen long terme
donc si jamais on trouve ça absolument
génial il ya de belles histoires à
raconter et le concerne est presque
qu'un prétexte en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est tout ce qui va se
passer en amont et en aval
donc c'est plutôt dans cette logique là
qu'il faudrait avancer plutôt que de se
dire qu'on va
avoir ce côté un peu maître d'école
donneurs de leçons en tout cas essayer
de les guider de manière trop formel sur
une thématique qui a un peu abrupte quoi
qui est un peu austère mais plutôt
l'enrobé de manière un peu sexy avec une
de l'un de leur principal centre un de
leurs principaux centres d'intérêt qui
est la musique parce que c'est un nombre
et thématiques nouvelles matières
faciles à travailler sur laquelle ils
réagissent immédiatement
beaucoup de réactivité voilà c'est
plutôt intéressant voilà juste un cas
extrêmement concret mais qui nous
semblent vraiment correspondre à l'air
du temps et qui est une démarche
positive sans qu'à aucun moment je pense
cette cible puisse imaginer qu'il y ait
récupération ou qu'elles soient
instrumentalisés voilà elle est active
et le participe elle est même le premier
acteur de l'opération c'est grâce à elle
si l'opération est un succès merci il
rendu
moi je pense que notre notre notre
métier
si on arrive à fédérer ces jeunes c'est
parce qu' on essaie d'être en phase avec
leurs centres d'intérêts donc c'est
forcément très difficile pour un média
qui qui est centrée sur le sur les
centres d'intérêt de des jeunes de
sortir de ce centre l'intérêt pour
parler d'autre chose parce que on prend
le risque de 2,2 nous aussi ne plus les
intéressés
donc tu pas prenons l'exemple de
l'éducation civique par exemple je pense
que c'est vraiment à l'école que ce doit
se faire qu on trouve des des relais
dans les médias pour déclencher des
choses je parle ne serait ce que dans
les médias jeunes que nous représentons
se forcer alors que l'on sait que c'est
pas forcément générateur d'audience de
prime abord de continuer de faire des
flashes d'information de présenter
l'information d'une certaine façon de
manière à ce qu elle soit reçue par les
jeunes en question ou par la plupart
d'autres d'entre eux en tout cas ça peut
rappeler à des choses qui se sont
passées à l'école mais si en amont tout
ça il ya une déscolarisation à l'âge de
14 ans nous en tant que média on peut
rien faire on pourra on pourra on pourra
rien rappeler à des gens qui n'ont rien
entendu
donc
la difficulté elle est pas pour botter
en touche mais allait elle est quand
même en amont et en premier lieu il ya
l'éducation il ya l'école il ya tout un
tas de choses qui se passent autour de
l'école autour des activités sportives
autour de d'une socialisation normal
qu'on apprend au fur et à mesure du
temps et si ça ça n'existe pas on peut
toujours avoir la meilleure volonté du
monde ccd génération de perdus après un
faux faut juste en être conscient mais
après après je dis on prend on prend on
prend de gros risques à à essayer à tout
prix de 2,2 rattraper de rattraper les
choses comme ça cc c'est la difficulté
tout ça maintenant c'est aussi on se
rend compte de plus en plus que je vous
disais entre le début d' ado fm et
maintenant tout a changé qu'est ce qui a
changé c'est que au début du day 2 fm la
radio c'était nouveau
donc il y avait un attrait pour la
nouveauté un attrait pour
certaines certaine forme de musique et
on sent que pour prendre pour conserver
le lien avec la nouvelle génération
il ne suffit plus de parler de musique
d'organiser des concerts c'est c'est
plus suffisant sa reste vrais pour
certainement une grande majorité des
gens mais encore une fois pour ceux
acquis en verre qui on a des difficultés
de communication nous aussi il faut
qu'on trouve d'autres moyens et on
s'évertue de réfléchir à trouver
d'autres moyens et on prend parfois les
uns et les autres des risques à sortir
de nos formats marketing initiaux pour
tester des choses et pour voir comment
les choses réagissent et souvent on a
des bonnes surprises alors il faut faut
se planter plusieurs fois pour réussir
quelque chose mais on a des bonnes
surprises et c'est pas forcément là où
on s'attendait à avoir avoir des
résultats positifs mais mais encore une
fois c'est c'est difficile quand on va
sur le terrain on se rend compte que
c'est complètement différent de ce qu'on
a comme l'impression en tant que média
en décrochant le téléphone et en
écoutant les auditeurs qui passe à la
radio c'est pas pas les mêmes gens qu'on
voit sur le terrain
nous on a une opération
en fait on emmène des artistes dans les
lycées ont fait gagner en fait à
l'antenne le droit à un élève de devenir
là la petite star de son lycée pendant
une journée parce que il va recevoir un
artiste qui vient en concert à paris et
on va lenval on va le chercher à la
sortie du lycée avec l'artiste et et là
on est confronté à la population à une
double population en fait la population
de ceux qui sont scolarisés
et puis comme on est à l'extérieur de
l'établissement et qu'on attend on a
souvent on est souvent en relation avec
des tensions avec ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur de l'établissement
parce que on amène des artistes on
essaye de ne pas amener des artistes
trop ghetto mais on a quand même du fait
de notre forme à un certain c'est qu'une
certaine typologie de musique conques en
diffuse donc on sent qu'il ya vraiment
une dichotomie entre ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur l'établissement et à
l'extérieur établissements quand on va
sur le terrain et ça on le ressent pas
quand on quand on parle à soi disant nos
auditeurs qui représente en théorie
l'ensemble de la population des jeunes
mais c'est donc voilà c'est pour vous
dire que c'est l'appréciation et les
différentes quand on est sur le terrain
et quand quand on est derrière derrière
nos consoles ça donne pas de solution en
est
ça nous allait réfléchir merci bien on
va passer aux questions madame dupont
est inscrite yad'autres d'inscrits mamie
du coup vous lisez quoi autres ebrel
d'ailleurs est ce que vous êtes capable
de donner le
le public que vous touchez le type de
public que vous touchez catégorie
j'allais dire social éventuellement quel
est le pourcentage des coûte radio et
les tranches horaires des radios parce
que je pense qu'il ya des concurrence
avec les nouveaux médias ne serait-ce
que de voir les enfants qui ont de plus
en plus accès à internet pour beaucoup
qui sont beaucoup beaucoup sur internet
et qui vous font de la concurrence
puisqu'il enregistre même leur musique
tout ça donc ils font des
enregistrements sauvages ils ont
beaucoup de dialogues individuel avec
leurs copains il reste entre bonnes
jambes entre bandes de copains
troisième question vous avez parlé vous
monsieur je crois que les appartements
un sujet qui les intéressait est-ce que
les recherches d'emplois éventuellement
les intérêts c est ce qu éventuellement
vous avez une possibilité de leur offrir
un petit peu d'orientations voire de
coaching dans le domaine et puis vous
avez parlé de la citoyenneté vous avez
les müller de dire vous monsieur que
c'était un petit peu difficile mais
quand par hasard le sujet passe je me
posais la question de savoir si par
exemple l'europe les intéressés et si
les élections européennes pouvaient
retenir leur attention
merci première vous laisse répondre à
cette première question sais pas qui
leur répond
pour ce qui est de parce que de la
dernière partie de votre question
l'europe jeu j'aurais eu du mal à vous
dire si quel est le niveau d'intérêt au
désintérêt j'ai plutôt l'impression que
c'est très éloignés de leurs
préoccupations et et mal malheureusement
je pense que ne sais pas c'est pas
uniquement quelque chose qui est liée
aux jeunes donc bon je pense que voilà
c'est ce etc
et puis j'ai oublié ce que vous avez
posé comme la première partie de votre
question c'est est oui alors ça pour ça
c'est relativement simple enfin on est
venu ni les uns les autres avec les
outils nécessaires mais je pense qu'on
pourrait s'engager à vous faire un petit
topo écrit parce qu'on a des études à
travers médiamétrie qui nous donne pour
chacun de nous a encore plus précisément
pour la télévision
les profils par tranche d'âge par
catégorie socioprofessionnelle par
tranche horaire
oui hommes femmes alors dans la limite
de l'exercice évidemment parce que ça
reste ça reste des chiffres et qui fait
d'un niveau statistique
et il faut bien prendre en compte les
marges d'erreur dans ces chiffres là
alors plus vous avez plus vous avez une
audience générale à la base qui est
forte plus vous pouvez vous permettre de
descendre dans des niveaux statistiques
de quelques de quelques marches sans
prendre de risques plus vous avez une
audience qui est faible plus les
chiffres que vous transmettra sont à
prendre avec précaution mais on a un
certain nombre d'éléments notamment sur
les répartitions hommes femmes c'est
quelque chose de crédible sur l'audience
générale sur les tranches horaires
on voit que en dehors de tout format la
radio en général s'écoute de la même
façon la télé en général ces écoutes de
la même façon donc on sait on sait à
quel endroit et les publicitaires
d'ailleurs sont des études très précises
sur les sur le sujet on sait public et
on pourrait on pourra vous faire si ça
vous intéresse
un petit topo là dessus en tout cas moi
je m'y engage si vous qui vous appelle
aux horaires scolaires ou bien si c'est
des enfants des jeunes qui sont plutôt
désoeuvrés qui vous appelle en cours de
journée
je sais ça c'est très difficile parce
que les gamins qui appellent enfin
souvent quand même les centres d'intérêt
qu'on détermine s'en sont liés avec avec
ce conte avec ce qu'on met en jeu donc
d'abord il faut être équipé d'un
téléphone pour communiquer avec une
radio ou faut être en liaison avec
internet et j'insiste là dessus parce
qu'on a on a vite fait de de croire que
aujourd'hui tout le monde est équipé
mais il y en a beaucoup et je dirais que
la proportion de ceux qui sont équipés
enfin je n'ai pas les chiffres exacts
mais je suis absolument certain que ce
qui pose problème
son sang parmi ceux qui sont qui ont le
moins de tout équipement et ceux avec
qui on a le plus de co2 de difficultés à
rentrer en contact sont parmi ceux qui
sont un peu en dehors de la société
donc on peut avoir l'impression de
parler aux jeunes mais pas de parler aux
jeunes à qui et à qui on a besoin de
parler parce que je sais de répondre
plus précisément sur la question de la
déclinaison d'une mission du type
recherche appartement sur recherche
d'emploi il ya peut-être une
problématique éditoriale c'est que vous
avez forcément un effet miroir sur
recherche d'appartement parce qu'on peut
tous se sentir concernés directement ou
de manière enfin en se projetant à
fortiori quand on a 16 ans sur l'emploi
c'est plus difficile parce que ce sont
forcément des cas particuliers donc ça
sera traité de manière forcément plus
sociétal c'est le cas parfois alors pas
forcément de cette manière là
précisément sous un angle différent par
exemple dans un zone interdite un des
grands succès je reviens cette émission
mais elle est censée quand même prendre
le pouls de manière assez correcte de la
société et les audiences montrent que
les thématiques les thèmes qui sont
traités un dimanche sur deux sont plutôt
en phase avec ce que vivent et ce
qu'attendent les français devant leur
télé en tout cas une des thématiques
récemment traité avec succès c'était
quand la france galère donc la
problématique de l'emploi était
forcément mises en avant pas que mais
forcément mises en avant je crois que ça
traités notamment du système d notamment
pour les gens qui avaient des preuves
alors je dis pas que ça ça donne des
clés pour pour ou du coaching pour
retrouver des emplois parce que ce
serait un peu prétentieux de
proposer ça mais c'est plus une photo de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
éventuellement peut-être quelques
exemples de parcours qui ont réussi à
s'en sortir qui arrive est d'assez bas
ou qui sont tombé assez bas qui ont
réussi à remonter donc en cela on peut
dire qu'on peut donner quelques clés à
travers des exemples personnels
au delà de ça c'est vrai que c'est un
peu compliqué ça dépend plus de la
manière dont on peut l'appréhender de
manière a dit orianne trouver la bonne
idée pour que ça puisse rassembler le
plus grand nombre et faire à voir venir
les gens à les faire rester ça me fait
penser à quelque chose c'est enfin je
sais pas pourquoi jérôme et j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il que que nos auditeurs
viennent vers nous sur cette thématique
enfin je regarde d'un peu plus près mais
je n'ai pas le sentiment que qui
viennent voilà ils viennent pas pour ça
et gênent pas pour se plaindre viennent
pas pour nous exposer leurs problèmes
donc on a des difficultés à les avoir le
temps pour ça il est le nombre je crois
que les statistiques les statistiques
qu'il a donné tout à l'heure son sang
sont là pour pour montrer que c'est
difficile quand quand quand on a combien
80000 personnes qui essaient de joindre
un standard et que 26 personnes
passeront leur voilà on peut on n'est
pas là pour ça passait donc et mais en
tout cas c'est ce que je voulais
vraiment vous dire c'est ça c'est que
les gens ne viennent pas vers nos médias
pour pour exposer pour s'exposer pour
parler de leurs problèmes
à moins qu'on a moins que sur des
émissions monter dans cette direction on
aille les chercher mais de manière
naturelle
ils ont tendance à passer s'exprimer sur
la question des audiences on peut voir
évidemment vous faire parvenir pas mal
de choses moi je peux faire plaisir yens
mais je peux vous dire que ça fait
plaisir c'est que la radio reste le
média préféré des jeunes hypermédia très
important dans l'esprit de la jeunesse
sur les saisons 5 et même une étude qui
s'appelle media in life
mais il ya une life de médiamétrie qui
montre qu'elles sont les médias
préférées des jeunes des moins de 30 ans
et la radio est encore en tête assez
largement d'ailleurs l'internet a fait
un bon évidemment depuis quelques années
mais la radio est et de loin encore le
média préféré la jeunesse donc à média
effectivement important sur les
initiatives des missions tu as donné un
bon exemple tout à l'heure je vais vous
en donner un autre avec une règle
générale qui à mon avis elle de ça peut
effectivement nous fait réfléchir à des
initiatives qui sont plus larges aux
différentes qui pourrait qui pourrait
nous inspirer ou vous inspirer dans les
politiques publiques c'est le fait
d'avoir une cause juste
ça c'est évidemment la première chose
peut-être qu'on a passé 10 mai d'avoir
des porte parole d'ard des gens qui
incarnent cette cause évidemment sur les
artistes avec lequel nous travaillons
c'est très fort dans la dimension de
concerts d'avoir des gens qui fédère les
jeunes encore faut-il que ces artistes
véhicule des valeurs positives mais il y
en a beaucoup qui le font et il faut le
souligner et la troisième c'est que tout
ça se cristallise autour d'événements et
a décrit est très fort et très juste et
nous travaillons d'ailleurs aussi je le
dis pas pour le vent mais pour
l'illustrer parce que ça fait partie du
dispositif comprend la matière sur des
choses qui tourne autour de l'écologie
donc comment traiter l'écologie qui
n'est pas forcément un truc très marrant
comme ça là mais qui est très important
et auquel nos auditeurs sont sensibles
voilà une fois qu'on a dit tout ça comme
on traite et ben en appliquant cette
règle si on peut dire que c'est une
règle en faisant un concert cpra le
green festival qu'on fera à la rentrée
avec une des radios qui est rtl2 en
déterminant des artistes qui vont porter
les messages de ce2 ce2 ce2 ce concert
qui participeront à ce concert qui sera
financée par des opérateurs privés sont
évidemment intéressé pour s'associer à
ce type d'opération d'image je suis
certain que les auditeurs seront
sensibles de venir sur cet événement ils
auront la fois sentiment de participer à
une cause juste tout en se divertissant
et tout en adhérant à un message qui à
la fois porté par la radio mais surtout
par les artistes qui sont parfaitement
cohérents avec ça et plus à des russes
voulaient le souligner parce que on vous
avait parlé des missions sur l'emploi
parce que c'est rtl qui leur fait est
une station du groupe mais il ya une
émission sans emploi qui est un énorme
succès ya dix jours rtl a fait une
limite à une journée spéciale en fait
sur l'emploi je vous l'avais remarqué
qu'ils étaient en fait la mise en
relation de demandes et d'offres
il se trouve qu'il ya eu 5000 mises en
relation c'est un très beau succès et
beaucoup de gens dire des témoignages
rtl n'a aucune vocation matière de
remplacement du pôle emploi évidemment
mais il ya eu des auditeurs qui appelait
pour dire c'est formidable parce que ce
qu'a fait la radio aujourd'hui le pôle
emploi l'a pas enfin je veux dire parce
que c'était comme ça l'a pas fait
pendant dix ans dans ces incroyables
à tel point d'ailleurs que l'opération
serait d'être à tous les ans fatou les
parents tous les mois tous les mois oui
mais là vous avez raison de le dire et
d'ailleurs il y aura une journée
spéciale sur les jeunes sur cette
initiative qui sera faite avant l'été
voilà simplement pour dire et il n'y a
pas plus d'ambition que ça mais que ça
c'est quand même initiative très
concrète et très positif qui a vraiment
marché quoi c'était vraiment bien et
quelques métiers comme ça avec des
grands témoins qui dirait je fais tel
métier c'est formidable c'est
extraordinaire histoire de donner des
idées aux jeunes qui n'en n'ont pas
c'était absolument deux cas s'étaient
alors et non seulement ça se déclinait
sur l'antenne ça se déclinait sur
l'internet aussi l'internet a été très
fort en la matière je pense qu'il ya
cette opération c'est une opération
spéciale je pense pas qu'elle ait
vocation à résoudre le problème de
l'emploi français n'ont pas la question
mais en tout cas c'était positif c'était
concret et ça a marché et je pense que
ça participe aussi de la valorisation
deux démarches qui était active concrète
et très efficace voilà et il y avait un
relais sur l'antenne et servira toute
l'année sur le site internet puisque on
a créé un site manants qui est
spécialement dédié à ça et encore une
fois n'a pas vocation à faire le nid a
remplacé le service public ce serait
bien prétentieux mais messi positive en
tout cas bien sûr d'ailleurs il y avait
les y avait les gens du pôle emploi qui
participait qui est évidemment
partenaires juste pour prolonger ce que
dit jérôme est pour revenir sur les
exemple concret et quand on voit les
succès qu'ont rencontré des actions soit
citoyennes humanitaires en faveur de
l'environnement etc
on voit bien qu'à chaque fois ça s'est
fait à travers le prisme du
divertissement et du plaisir
les restos du coeur restos du coeur
c'est quand même une énorme fête qui a
lieu à bercy par les gens viennent et en
l'occurrence assez la carotte c'est
qu'ils sont récompensés de les
volontaires sont récompensés de de toute
l'action terrain qu'il a effectué toute
l'année mais bon ils savent qu'il ya au
bout alors dans quelle mesure ça joue
peut-être qu'au bout d'un moment c'est
oublier au contact de ceux qui souffrent
et de du bonheur voilà de bons esprits
de tout ça mais je viens c'est quand
même très important ça a été lancée dans
des conditions assez exceptionnelles
avec coluche et c'est donc il y avait à
nice pour une espèce de porte-parole à
gaza avec une symbolique forte
il ya d'autres exemples il y avait
notamment quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a
relié sur m6 avec un grand succès
d'audience il ya de cela cinq ou six ans
qui s'appelait le live est l'initiative
de bob geldof juste avant le sommet du
g8 qui allait étudier la question de
l'annulation de la dette du tiers-monde
donc à une hanche fort deux jours après
ils ont réussi à mobiliser
la population de 12 pays qui ont chacun
héberger un concert qui était qui avait
lieu au même moment dans le monde entier
et vous aviez je crois à près de 180
diffuseur donc avec des milliards de
téléspectateurs
au même moment sur la planète il ya même
eu un moment magique où chacune des
chaînes
pardon chacune des scènes c'est un show
à la télé se relayer et s'interpeller
c'est will smith qui a donné je me suis
le signale à philadelphie il avait
appelé londres ensuite paris etc
et on est dans quelque chose
d'extrêmement festif mais qu'il y avait
un objectif clairement affiché qui était
d'obtenir de faire pression sur les
gouvernements pour qu'ils décident tous
ensemble d'annuler la dette du
tiers-monde purement et simplement ou le
live earth qui deux ans plus tard
souhaité sensibiliser à travers un grand
concert volume principe d'ailleurs c'est
plusieurs concerts au même moment dans
le monde entier sur la question
environnementale
alors on voit bien qu'à chaque fois les
grands succès ont été faits avec une
logique beaucoup plus globale et surtout
pas donneuse de leçons quelque chose
extrêmement festif même blandin et jean
desessard chacun posez votre question et
vous répondre et messieurs globalement
s'il vous plaît
on s'arrêtera là il ya déjà eu beaucoup
de réponses parce que j'avais à peu près
le
il est question également que madame
dupont
donc moi j'aurais voulu que c'est vrai
j'aurais voulu quand même réagir un
petit peu à la description qui nous a
été faite des demandes des jeunes
vous nous avez parlé des demandes de
respect des demandes d'autorité
également moi je
c'est vrai que je viens d'un monde
enseignant et c'était exactement dans
les classes avec les jeunes c'est
exactement cela qu'il demandait et clive
je suppose qu'ils demandent toujours
donc c'est pas très étonnant leur vision
de l'avenir leurs projections vous avez
évoqué ce cette demande de projet que
cette vision de l'avenir un petit peu
pessimistes qu'ils avaient je pense pas
que ça ait beaucoup changé c'est pour ça
que je voulais vous demander vous avez
répondu monsieur depuis combien de temps
faites vous de la radio et des
programmes pour les jeunes parce que
comment expliquez-vous que vous si vous
le demandez vous le constater maintenant
alors que c'était déjà des constats qui
ont été faits avant pensez vous qu'il ya
eu une accélération de la société qui
fait que les jeunes se sont prononcés là
dessus un peu plus violemment ou plus
fortement dans vous dans vos programmes
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de la
radio comme étant le média le plus
utilisé par les jeunes on a aussi
beaucoup parlé des jeunes qui étaient la
génération zapping est ce que vous le
constatez
chez vous ou comment peut-on le
constater et j'avais aussi une question
sur l' influence parce qu'on dit que la
jeunesse est aussi influencée par les
programmes etc et tous ses programmes
comme star ac ou les shows réalité et
autres pensées vous qui lisez aussi
quelques influences sur leurs réactions
et le traitement de l'actualité
vous avez
vous avez dit que c'était finalement la
musique le plaisir qui était le fil
conducteur des programmes que vous
élaborez pour les jeunes est-ce que vous
partez de temps en temps sur un fait
divers
et est-ce qu'à partir d'un fait divers
je prends un exemple ce qui s'est passé
à strasbourg ce que vous pensez pouvoir
l'utiliser pour amener les jeunes à
s'exprimer à avoir des réactions là
dessus jean desessard pose ces questions
vous répondez globalement 20 jeux
olympiques rio
alors non sur le sur le fait que comment
dire sur l'histoire de faim sur distance
sur le
savoir si la jeunesse va - plus mal ou
moins mal bon c'est un peu difficile à
dire mais ce que je moi ce que je pense
quand même bon ça fait quand même dix
ans je fais ce métier je moi je veux
dire en tant que citoyen finalement pas
uniquement en tant que directeur de
radio directeur de deux chaînes moi je
pense que dès qu'ils sont plus visibles
plus criants plus dramatique qu'avant ça
j'en suis convaincu et moi je deux
exemples de thèmes le tout ce qui a
trait à la précarité étudiante à la
pauvreté
des enfants des adolescents
est devenu beaucoup plus je trouve
beaucoup plus visible beaucoup plus
grave beaucoup plus intense et non le
ressent fortement dans les appels
entrants qu'on a sur nous sur nos
standards téléphoniques et un deuxième
thème
donc je vous ai mentionné tout à l'heure
auxquelles je crois aussi beaucoup je
pense que la fracture avec les
populations issues de la diversité est
devenue insupportable
voilà et je veux il ya une vienne vrai
et cette fracture est devenue de plus en
plus visible est peut-être difficile à
assumer pour ces populations sur le sur
la génération zapping
c'est clair qu'on est dans une
d'ailleurs on en est nous mêmes un peu
victime parce que les radios musicales
où une audience qui a plutôt baissé
non je préfère la la revente on est on
est pas très concernés par cette baisse
mais l'ensemble du marché des radios
musicales a plutôt baissé les autres
évidemment mais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que c'est abc voulez vous l'avez
dit leur d'ailleurs on est concurrencés
pas tellement d'ailleurs par les radios
musicales
c'est le contexte concurrentiel a
totalement changé cercle il ya
l'internet et les baladeurs mobiles mais
il n'ya pas que ça il ya aussi les
consoles de jeux vidéo il ya le pc fait
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer en termes de
supports multimédias qui fait que le
temps n'est pas n'est pas extensible à
l'infini dans une journée où dans une
fin de journée qui fait quelques heures
on peut pas tout faire en même temps
même s'ils aiment la radio cet avantage
formidable à la différence de la
télévision d'être un média synchronique
sait qu'on peut faire autre chose tout
en écoutant la radio
malgré tout le temps accordé à la radio
a un peu diminué et les musiques alençon
en sont aussi victimes
et je pense que les les jeunes à plus
d'un média à l'autre ils sont plus
sollicités donc ils passent plus d'une
chose à l'autre
il a plus des choses qu'ils aiment pas
et il a plus les choses dont il estime
qu'on est dans les paires marty qu'on le
veut leur vendre des choses qui sont
préfabriqués ou pas pas ou qui en fait
ne leur correspondent pas oui je pense
je vous citerai venir en personne mais
je pense à des marques je pense année je
pense à des cas concrets où visiblement
on est dans un effet de cycle qui fait
qu' il ya une prise de conscience que le
discours n'est pas sincère
d'où nous ce qu'on a tiré comme
conclusion c'est d'avoir un discours qui
sont un discours très sincère très vrai
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de vie des vis
des jeunes en général encore c'est vrai
que tu l'éditeur les jeunes en général
c'est un vaste mots on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé de ça mais que moi il ya deux
convictions de geste et moi c'est
évidemment les jeunes c'est les jeunes
et quand on l'a 13 ans vous pourrez pas
le losc à 25 ans mais surtout par contre
ça c'est peut-être nouveaux
c'est qu'on est jeune anthony mais de
plus en plus tôt dire que les gens sont
de plus en plus éveillés et que les gens
qui ont 12 outre en tout cas on est un
jeune consommateur de plus en plus tôt
ouais non mais c'est vrai que les je
pense je sais c'est pas faire insulte
aux personnes qui ont cet âge là de dire
que mes parents je pense était fall les
gens qui ont aujourd'hui 12 13 ans on
sait comme ça aussi ont une ouverture
c'est pas toujours positifs dont un
éveil par rapport à plein de sujets et
ce qui est important moins manger cette
conviction la gc qu'ont-ils son site par
rapport à mes enfants
c'est que je pense que on peut pas
interdire ne peut pas cacher les choses
par contre de d'éveiller la conscience
critique la lecture critique ou les
coudes critique de des contenus pour
savoir les décoder éventuellement les
mettre à distance
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
et encore une fois je travaille sur un
média qui est engagée sur cette voie
veuillez compléter ou non mais vous
répondre à une autre mine parce que ma
question va les dents on va vous aider
même puisque j'ai déjà partiellement de
une réponse la première question c'était
combien de personnes à peu près s'occupe
du des remontées d informations
puisque vous avez qu à 80 mille
personnes en contact faux billets des
personnes qui regardent ce qui s'est dit
sur l'internet et pour le standard et
tout ça en mille appels je vous rassure
oui mais on a un standard qui compte le
nombre d'appels entrants mais on a on
prend pas on peut pas prendre évidemment
les mais les personnes qui prennent les
messages par internet et par
téléphone ça fait combien de personnes
alors les choses sont pas tellement
organisé comme ça parce qu'elles sont
organisées par émission mais on a une
petite dizaine de personnes sur
l'internet et au standard téléphonique
qui s'occupe de da faut écouter les
auditeurs de traiter les sujets ou leur
demander éventuellement nous faire
remonter les informations sur les
différents sujets et d'eau et donc ma
question qui essuie donc c'est qu'est ce
qui ressort le plus mais vous avez en
partie répondu hein
c est ce que c'est les poèmes les à
l'école ou à l'institution scolaire est
ce que c'est le problème du revenu
financier est ce que c'est pour mon
copain comment avoir un copain ou
comment regarder ou comment masser par
éventuellement ou une copine s'est elle
serait le poème de logements et puis là
c'est les discriminations visiblement
enfin qu est ce qui ressort le plus
comme ray vous parisien du soir
notamment
oui alors moi je voudrais que le thème
numéro un vous faut pas s'en cacher mais
c'est quand même question qui agite
beaucoup d'enfants enfin d'enfants
d'adolescents c'est l'histoire d'amour
ce qui est important c'est je vais vous
dire franchement moins la conviction
j'ai encore une fois ce qui est
important ce n'est pas tellement le
sujet ce qui est important c'est la
façon dont répond et la façon dont tout
ça dans quel environnement programme on
aime ça c'est très important et il faut
suffit de si vous avez accusé vous
brancher sur les antennes jeunes le soir
vous avez trois grosses antennes jeunes
qui font de la libre antenne et il ya
trois façons de traiter les sujets qui
est un peu différente qui fait que
chaque radio à son positionnement aussi
mais vous avez des façons plus ou moins
graveleuses ou plus ou moins sérieuses
ou plus ou moins obscène
voilà on va dire ça comme ça de répondre
aux questions voilà c'est tout ensuite
il ya les donc l histoire d'amour il ya
des histoires au lycée avec les profs il
ya l'histoire familiale
vous êtes très informés absolument
mais c'est les histoires en gros c'est
l'histoire de la vie quotidienne c'est
vraiment la vie quotidienne et en
général et évidemment ils viennent là
parce que ils pensent qu'ils vont
pouvoir dialoguer où ils pensent ils
pensent à juste titre souvent
heureusement ils vont pouvoir dialoguer
avec un avis extérieur qui va pouvoir
les aider à progresser sur le sujet et
que c'est une question qui n'ont pas pu
résoudre dans le cadre familial immédiat
et moi je voudrais juste rajouter
quelque chose par rapport à la question
vous posiez sur le temps qui est passé
sur est-ce que c'est tellement différent
moi j'ai non seulement la sensation que
que c'est pas tellement différent mais
que si on va un cran plus loin et si on
revient moi j'ai quarante voire 46 ans
aujourd'hui la première conscience non
mais on voit aujourd'hui pendant ces
jours ci je si je reviens la première
conscience que j'ai eues en écoutant la
radio
quand j'avais
12 13 ans c'était le premier choc
pétrolier
et depuis ce moment là j'ai l'impression
qu'on me parle de crise
donc je suis un enfant de la crise et
depuis depuis que je suis jeune et plein
d'autres jeunes qui ont toujours entendu
parler de la crise et je pense que ça
c'est un n'a pas changé et que bon c'est
certainement plus aiguë dans certaines
classes il ya certainement plus de leleu
la valeur absolue le nombre a grandi
mais mais mais les mots sont toujours
les mêmes les gens sont ghettoïsés et ça
ça date pas d'hier
donc on commence à travailler il ya il
ya que y'a que 5 ou peut-être sept ans
que j'ai commencé à entendre parler des
premiers les premiers immeubles qu'on
dynamitait qui est qu'il donnait le leu
leu pour moi en tout cas celui ressenti
comme ça et je pense que l'intérieur de
ces ghettos ça a été aussi ressenti
c'est le top départ de peut-être une
nouvelle organisation
alors que on vient tous deux des grandes
promesses de jean nouvel qui n'ont pas
trouvé preneur et donc ça vient ça vient
de loin et je pense que c'est ce qui ce
qui ce qui surgit aujourd'hui face qui
donne l'impression que ressurgit
aujourd'hui ça vient de bien plus loin
que les jeunes aujourd'hui ça vient
d'eux peut être deux trois générations
de jeunes
pense avoir été adolescentes dans les
années 50 de 54 donc on a vécu l'abbé
pierre en 54 dont vous étiez encore deux
plus jeunes que moi
et bien en fait tous tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui moi je les ai vécus
jeunes filles on trouvait pas de
logement
il n'y avait pas d'emploi alors après on
a vécu les trente glorieuses
alors évidemment vous êtes tous les
descendants des trente glorieuses tout
vous paraît très difficile au jour
d'aujourd'hui mais en fait on est dans
un espèce de mouvements répétitifs et on
est en train de revivre ce qu'on a vécu
après les années de guerre et après les
années de guerre la vie était très
difficile vous vous mariez en 54 la 500
cochons et bien vous n'avez pas de
logement vous payés horriblement cher
une piaule avec un cabinet de toilette
qui ressemble à rien c'est pas si
évident que ça et je pense que c'est le
fait d'avoir vécu trente années très
riche qui fait qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
on est on a tous peur finalement on a
tous peur en principe à belles années de
guerre il ya du travail
moche 1h46 donc après la guerre celui
qui voulait travailler d'abord c'était
la seule issue quand on les quatorze
finlande l'issue qu'on avait c'était de
trouver de travail il y avait aucun
système parallèle qui permet tait de
faire croire qu'on pouvait s'en sortir
le seule issue c'est être connaissez
français travaillent et moi 17 18 ans
j'étais bûcheron voilà mais aujourd'hui
il ya plus de monde il ya aussi plus de
monde et donc moins de place et il ya
autant de surface de forêt elle est
moins bien que ce côté qu'elle n'était
et messi le rapporteur pour une annonce
merci madame la présidence tout à
l'heure reçu faudrait vous ai pas être
porte-parole faut des bons porte-parole
pour des bonnes causes
il ya cette mission aujourd'hui a
vraiment besoin de porte parole alors on
fait pas de musique on peut pas de
concert c'est vrai que la mission n'est
pas très sexy elle a quand même on la
cour mais on a quand même créé un blog
alors j'ai pas s'ils pouvaient nous
aider on en parlait à l'antenne en
donnant l'adresse du blog ce qui nous
intéresse il voulait savoir des retours
de jaune alors moi sur la musique mais
sur les difficultés qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer sur ce qu ont évoqué la
formation l'orientation de logements
donc vous ces adresses et puis vous en
faites ce que vous voulez et donc ce
blog ou low loss à la fin de cette
semaine
fan de ce blog on virait présentation
l'objectif d'un blog c2 alors vous
voulez donner ctp donc point de bach
blog au pluriel point senat.fr cela john
au pluriel et slash ou ma ville de l'est
tout de suite voilà
tenez souhaite d'acier
on va mettre fin à cette table ronde le
nouveau remercions vraiment très
sincèrement d'être d'être venu merci
pour pour la simplicité et la sincérité
de vos propos et vous nous apportez
vraiment quelque chose de tout à fait
complémentaire avec les auditions
auxquelles on a pu procéder
préalablement donc voila moi je suis
ravi de le soyez venu merci nous avoir
on s'est consacré du temps
voilà pour cette table-ronde cet
après-midi la mission d'information
commune du sénat sur la politique en
faveur des jeunes poursuit ses auditions
elle entendra à fadela amara la
secrétaire d'état chargée de la
politique de la ville je vous donne donc
rendez vous sur notre antenne à 16h30
merci de votre fidélité et à très
bientôt sur public sénat